okay
last time we went on a trip through
nostalgiaville to see which video game
makes you really feel like you can do
whatever a spider can
so let's move on to web of shadows shall
we
i can't skip this one can i
no
there was also spider-man 3 the game
we don't talk about that one ever
except for right now i originally
planned to review the ps2 copy
until i found out how embarrassingly
stripped down for content it was
so i spent about 18 getting a ps3 copy
so i could have a credible review of
this in full
i'm not gonna [ __ ] about one third of a
game as if it's a whole product
after playing both i immediately noticed
that bruce campbell's amazing tutorial
section
is just so dull in the ps3 version
he makes jokes and sarcastic remarks in
the other one but
here he's all business what the hell
happened
what would spider-man be without his
spider powers
i'll tell you he'd be man
is that what you came here to play man
three i don't think so now go ahead and
crawl up this wall you know
like spider-man you gotta take care of
those bombs
just crawl up the wall and onto the
ceiling
get it together bruce be more mean to me
i deserve it so the first real mission
is about learning how to swing and
taking mary jane on your back
this looks like a terrible dating sim
next thing it's going to have an awkward
dialogue tree where if i say all the
right things she'll invite me inside her
apartment to kawaii her desu
i don't know what that means i'm
spider-man and you have me swinging
through
giant spinning heart icons while mary
jane
tells me what to do because petey's a
totally whipped [ __ ]
i want to go even higher that leads into
this cutscene where we introduced the
crux of this game's plot
this is the lead up to finding the black
suit
compare this to uh secret wars what
and the graphics are nothing short of
hilarious
look at jay jonah jameson's face
good god it's like a silly g mod
animation but that's just the actual cut
scenes
the character models are hideous
this is mostly gonna be complaints about
the game so let me do a quick recap of
things i
like one cool thing is you can activate
your spider sense
and it's a lot like the detective mode
in the arkham series
though this one came out first so it
innovated slightly i guess
the side missions are a little less
repetitive and don't piss me off but
anything is a step
up from delivering pizzas
just in time i'm starving there are
combat tours and races but those aren't
fun enough for me want to actually do
them
i'm not required to either so i just
don't do like half the side activities
i like the ones where you have to take
pictures of stuff for the bugle
because it doesn't require me to have to
be good at punching and kicking people
i like that new york is well modeled and
feels like the right size in comparison
to spider-man
it's a very lively city and it feels
like stuff is going on everywhere
it's not quite liberty city but it's
fine as far as environments go
a big selling point for this game was
the fact that the hero work spills down
into the sewers and subways
so there's more variety from the
buildings i like that you can go down in
the sewers and it's all totally modeled
it makes the city feel more dense now
onto things that suck which is a lot
the swinging is just ah it feels so slow
it's like a chore at the start
spider-man feels too heavy and can't go
as fast as you should
spider-man you fat ass you also can't go
up holy [ __ ] i just want to go up
up want to be able to gauge the quality
of a spider-man game
look for two things how does central
park look
how long does it take you to swing all
the way to the top of the empire state
building
web zips permitted no wall chrome just
time
huh
good lord that long
either way you start to get the hang of
it and it feels a little faster but it's
never fun enough that you just
want to do it for fun you know
it's just something you'll do for travel
only
the combat is so aggressively
bad the dodge button is l1 and you have
to hold it down for a second to get it
to work
which is really hard to hit multiple
times in a row and quick enough to avoid
split-second attacks
eventually you just start using this
dumb bullet time mechanic
every time for the entire fight so it
isn't about timing your dodges or
counter-attacks you know like
strategy or playing the game
it's about entering a mode where you can
just not get hit
and then you wait for it to wear off so
you can use it again right away
no strategy just button mash and
sometimes spider-man will do something
cool
health doesn't regenerate until you beat
a mission so i'll get my ass kicked at
the start of one by some ninjas or punk
rockers with a stop sign
and i have to keep going with the whole
mission before i get more
it's so difficult and tedious you feel
so underpowered
and other times you feel too powerful
it's so unbalanced look at me kick this
giant monster's ass
what a punk and the sound effects are so
dull it's this tiny noise that sounds
like
someone putting down their backpack too
quickly
correlating to hitting someone hard
enough to knock them down the street
the combat also doesn't help with the
fact that most of these bosses are just
terrible none of them are particularly
difficult but
time consuming you have to punch craven
in the face 2
345.6 times before you can activate a
cutscene and stop fighting him
this game is giving me carpal tunnel
from playing these monotonous mashing
sequences
over and over every boss fight is like
this i can't do
anything to phase these guys [ __ ]
just let me get to the credits dammit
i think one of my biggest problems is
the fact that this doesn't bring
anything new to the table
it's really just a mess of stolen ideas
and very little new things beyond the
spider sense
but you rarely ever use it and they
substitute quicktime events for genuine
gameplay in a lot of scenes
what was the point of this scene i could
have just swung right over
why did they add that it's so pointless
that was like 10 hours of work
for nothing everything either feels
unnecessary or like it's been done
before
spider-man stopping a train with his
webs done
fighting tons of lizards people in the
sewers done it
they even ripped off the sound effects
of ultimate beatles jet pack for this
dumb unibomber villain
come on harry let's go find somewhere
cooler to fight this place sucks
follow me let's go fight on top of the
empire state building
um wait this is hard to categorize
you know what just i i have a new
category of things
a whole bunch of stupid [ __ ] why are the
random lizard people attacks in the city
if dr connors is still in his lab at the
university when did he have time to
escape and cultivate a mass population
of lizard people in the new york sewage
system by infecting random citizens and
dragging them into the creepy cavernous
lair
not with the big words again when
spider-man's taking photos of the
fashion show in the park and a random
fight breaks out over the biased judge's
pick for miss new york
how does spider-man switch into his new
costume so quickly unnoticed
does it not cause a public outcry
against spider-man for beating up a
bunch of unruly models in public
spider-man for some reason refuses to
stop this in-progress heist just to take
a few pictures of it like a greedy
douche and then says
i'll just fix it later this
okay i need to be stealthy so i'll land
on top of this trolley with a completely
translucent
outer shell they'll never see me up here
so dr connors is being hunted by calypso
and craven
you following okay they chase him into
this power station from the sewers and
i'm about to go after them
but after i walk into the room where all
three of them should be it's just
conor's by himself as a 19 foot tall
kaiju that spits acid with an energy
shield around him that protects him from
all kinetic force
i have so many questions about this
the biggest being why okay i guess i
should talk about the story at some
point
this game almost ignores the two before
it
and has no sense of continuity rhino and
scorpion were in the previous ones but
it acts as if these are new characters
so that's pretty lame and poopy and
makes me mad and stuff the plot of the
movie is here
minus the dancing and crying and they
completely cut out the part about
sandman killing uncle ben
instead spider-man just gets the black
suit out of nowhere and immediately
murders sandman
4 minutes later with no justifiable
cause
the plot of the movie wasn't great but
at least there was a modicum of emotion
in that scene
here it's just wow black suit is red
better go kill someone right away and by
the way
there are 42 missions in the game you
get the suit on like number 25.
this was the whole point of the game and
i have to wait until i'm more than
halfway through to use it
and all it does is give you this rage
meter that you can do extra damage with
when it's full
all you get is that in a move set that's
barely different
the black suit is completely malignant
it doesn't even make peter
evil he just says things that are weird
and overly aggressive
but not necessarily wrong or mean the
only prey truly worthy of my talents
i've waited so long for this moment
yeah i'm waiting to knock that smirk off
your face
so eager good
unless of course he's talking to mary
jane
that's when he becomes a total prick
you've hardly said three words all night
is everything all right
i figured you were talking enough for
both of us peter
what's gotten into you lately nothing
that's stopping your gums from flapping
wouldn't saul
that's right petey you tell that abusive
spouse of yours who's boss
she's not gonna get away with taking
advantage of you as a taxi service
anymore
thanks for coming you're so much faster
than a cab
made it with time to spare thanks for
the lift
i'll see you later so yeah therefore he
swings too quickly and makes mary jane
mad i guess
he gets butt hurt about it so he visits
the church from daredevil to get rid of
the thing that makes him way better
crime fighting
oh and eddie brock eddie brock has no
reason to want to destroy spider-man
other than he punched him once he didn't
knock him out or
hurt him he just gave him a little love
tap
then took away his falsified pictures of
spider-man committing a crime
eddie's career is fine his reputation is
fine
he's capable of supporting himself
financially
he can even totally get a girlfriend at
some point and settle down with a family
he wasn't publicly shamed at all
he was just mildly embarrassed in an
alley that no one else was in
why does he want to hold children
hostage in order to get sandman to
support his murder scheme against
spider-man
also this game doesn't cover that
sandman is still alive or why he steals
things
or even that he has a daughter but we
should care for some reason
because it happened in the movie right
venom is this
now let's talk about how we're going to
destroy
the spider
do i need to say anything else on it it
seems pretty self-explanatory
i usually have more of a conclusion or
an analysis on this stuff but this story
is so
dumb i can't write anything intelligent
response
it just gets so much wrong and plays
like a mess of derpy animations and
weird writing
the gameplay is tedious and painful and
there isn't any redeeming factors
i have no huge thing that i can remember
as a good point or a fun mission or a
nice detail
the best way to describe it is just that
this game is an awkward train wreck and
i recommend
everyone play it for comedy purposes
alone
this whole thing is a hilarious farce
what's the magic word
i was thinking please but whatever
everyone needs to experience this weird
mess at least
once in their lifetime
oh that was fun
leave it for the bomb squad yeah
whatever
from now on i am the bomb squad
who are you the bomb squad
you